il flotte un parfum d'amour sur les
étals de cette fleuriste de nevers jour
de saint valentin oblige toute l'équipe
s'affaire sur le banc alors y est on va
sortir également les gens qui pour
l'occasion la boutique s'est paré de
rouge incontournable elle plaît toujours
donc différentes variétés pour ce jour
spécial ici on a prévu 20 % de roses
rouges en plus est certaines viennent de
très loin des reculs m l'équateur des
routes du commerce équitable des
incontournables décliné sous toutes les
formes et qui ne séduisent pas que les
amoureux des commerçants de la ville
s'approvisionne pour offrir des roses à
leurs clients les roses vont servir pour
les clientes qui vont venir au sein de
coiffure cheap à nevers pour une
prestation lui offre une rose c'est pour
offrir à mes clientes de toute la
journée voilà toute personne qui viendra
dans ma boutique s'arrose
mais pourquoi avoir cette petite
attention on veut j'aime bien gâter mes
clients voilà chez des habitués et je
pense qu'ils apprécieront la saint
valentin un jour important pour le
commerce de cette fleuriste la saint
valentin
évidemment il ya aussi noël est la fête
des mères mais bon ça reste
une journée importante pour pour le
commerce des fleurs dans cette boutique
les clients dépenseront en moyenne entre
30 et 40 euros pour faire plaisir à leur
moitié